je trouve super simulateur à nouveau
simulateur qui est d'apparaître sur
steam est ce que c'est un bon simulateur
ok alors on est en ours effectivement
nourrir un de plus basique qu'un ours on
peut dormir sur cette butte de terre
ceci est un insecte
nous allons le manger aller on dégage
dégage va chercher dicaprio on va le
bouffer et on vole son oscar [ __ ]
spationautes en bourse
c'est vraiment une vie hors norme un cap
à une quête un objectif s'il vous plaît
un dans ce jeu là la fête juste malade
et à mon dieu un canard non entend
carrément mais je l'attends chez par
atterrir sur ces malfaiteurs atterrir tu
arrives à te la stratosphère bientôt ça
suffit harek canal ça y est c'est
désintégrer plus tard de la peinture
rouge avec un veste et de sentir pour
comprendre ça d'accord je peux pas il
faut 11 d'intelligence pour pouvoir
manger ça non mais c'est une blague mais
non pas la stratosphère arrête ton
camarade a brûlé déjà là haut à la parra
auteur tonga temps vous gâtera padel
tape à l'oeil tu crèves
t'as pas d'elle tu crèves maasing ça
valait le coup d'acheter ce jeu 15 euros
juste pour tuer un lapin je peux manger
mais ça ne donne plus un run puisses un
jump us 25 points de mana jeu très dur
actuellement je suis un [ __ ] de la
parole et on continue au et un mur là
qui dit mur dit humain pas loin qui
dumas pas loin d'y dicaprio avec son
oscar
quand l'ours de ce revenant veut lui
aussi son oscar ok on trouve le mur
c'est parfait sopra le mandat fois que
y'a personne là bas est une ville je
peux pas ya là-bas prend la bonne
bouille qui jette ses bouteilles la
[ __ ] ça s'éduque a plu au saloon axé
sur gala bien là vient la viande à bien
l'action tu vas buggé et courir dans le
vide comme à chaque fois mais c'est un
sketch via la [ __ ] n'a pas il s'est
noyé
d'accord mais c'est un sketch et la
promesse bévière la halle est de marier
[ __ ] mon gars tu apprends tarifs pour
tous et la fin de cette forêt on a 2 de
bâtiments on va aller les visiter et va
rien à voir dedans je suis ce jeu est
nul c'est un vieux squat d'accord
ce plasma la fois que non non mais j
aime les zorra mec connard du canard à
la la c'est quoi c'est un bâtiment ne
met que c'est quoi ce jeu 15 euros et le
pire c'est que ce jeu a été créé suite
inscrite harper qui a marché qui a
récolté 100 mille dollars quand même le
sens tellement violé humilié au c'est
une poule on s'extasie de voirie en son
palais stakes nos publics c'est à temps
je sais qu'on voit cgc on n'a qu'à
brûler des fermes toute notre vie oh
what you're gonna do à l'étiquette u17
absolument rien cette zone à part des
déchets comme d'habitude mais ce jeu
vidéo est-il vrai jeu venant rejoindre
ce n'est pas le fruit de mon imagination
avez-vous des choix qu'on vient de faire
le tour du jeu sans déconner 108 dollars
pour faire trois maisons et de forêts
[ __ ] ça valait le coup j'ai vu que le
jeu était donnée positivement où il y
avait que des revues ou négative et je
suis sûr et certain que les mecs ont
fait une review c'est le mec qui ont
donné aux geeks starter et ils sont
ultra déçu 1 n'a jamais tout supprimons
gars n'a jamais été aussi près attention
non non mais c'est pas possible c'est
comme les voitures et l'équiper de
caméras tous deux tours de vis butin
d'animal ça sonne dans son dans sa tête
bien là l'a pas bien là je vais te toute
consolation bah oui il ya allez arrête
ça suffit je suis le seul [ __ ] dehors
de cette forêt je n'aime pas de deux
copains hausse pour un musée j'espère au
moins que les développeurs utiliseront
mais 15 euros à bon escient qu'ils
achèteront des grecs
mais si tes pensées 15 euros d'en
acheter un pc par exemple pour coder un
autre jeu valache proteste vas-y je vais
dormir je veux dormir peut-être que en
me réveillant lama pourra changer on
s'assure un autre jeu et nous on s'est
toujours merci mais nathan [ __ ] balla
voulait gagner un point quand même un
changement de météo news bilitis mail
mois pour sortir des tâches là alors là
ce gameplay excitant où elle atteint là
où l'orgasme be careful fred je pense
que les ours vivent ici
d'accord donc j'ai vraiment mis vingt
minutes à pour la capacité renifler j'ai
senti cette morgue pour qu'on me dise
qu'elle est source dans la forêt c'est
un sketch l'oscar du sketch est remis à
bir simulator pas avoir eu de bonnes je
suis pas gêné j'ai le droit sur ce jeu
en regarderai ce petit passage étroit là
entre ces deux murs bon dieu mais où ça
nous mêmes de la morgue
[ __ ] enfin la capacité renifler 2 je
suis jamais venu ici et c'est un animal
légendaire c'est totalement faux je sais
je sais mais holla holla attendez
attendez attendez soit un truc l'espace
un truc regardez ça c'est un passage en
fait je pour aller sur la rive d'en face
papa mon cas on peut marcher sur les
manches pour un champignon plus un swing
waouh
super on pourra mieux nager tout ça pour
ça non alors là je tiens à vous dire que
c'était le passage de la vidéo n'hésitez
pas à vous mettre à j'aime quand même
pour cette action hors du commun à vous
abonner à monsieur sur tous les réseaux
a recommandé ma chaîne youtube à vos
parents je peux plus bouger
je suis stocks mais non non c'est un
sketch à metz m'a poussé mais non mais
c'est quoi ce jeu qu'en l'espace d'une
seconde ta passion pour le jeu vidéo est
un art chez moi de jouer nova zone ni de
gorge alors la world gets de red hat
frink les baous qu'à sa porte mais ni la
bourse pour la disparition des abeilles
il veut te prendre par les sentiments
pour qu'on mette une bonne note au jeu
sur steam jamais il aura ta bonne note
bercy bellator c'est fini à temps on va
tenter d'aller par là on a besoin 77 de
chances cette mi saison soit nommé que
vous avez vu les conditions quoi pour
ouvrir une porte ou les capacités de
l'ingénieur progressait de porte on
arrive dans une ville va se faire ce
naïf et je vois la tour hawaïen saiper
on arrive dans les montagnes de calypso
là il y aura de la chevelure labiche
l'art soyez prudents les amis cette zone
est une mauvaise aura ça marche
oh mon dieu ça alors défoncé mais non
mais non mais c'est un sketch malgré le
combat du siècle
voilà ça dure et seule seconde agen
d'appels de sos gamer en détresse vous
me conseillez la pendaison
très bien merci ça va pas du tout ce cap
se détache on va les jonquiérois que
cette vidéo sur pire simulator n'hésitez
pas à aller mais ça vous a plu
si on a quatre j'aime je comprendrais ne
vous en faites un an mais le problème
c'est que c'est pas du tout assez bien
foutu pour être un vrai simulateur et
que c'est pas du tout assez drôle pour
être une parodie de simulateurs comme
god simulator du coup s'est perdu dans
le néant du jeu vidéo et ça vole 15
euros au gamer qui passent par là
normalement vous êtes hyper heureux
puisque vous vous dites que votre
journée géniale comparé à la mienne je
vous n'avez pas dépenser 15 euros dans
ce jeu soyez heureux le sourire
aujourd'hui à la prudence est prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien tient tout le
monde pis